eu gosto mais caras livrar das máscaras
escondem as pessoas escondem as verdades
nós usamos máscaras normalmente para o
carnaval por exemplo porque nós queremos
porque saímos da nossa realidade e é tão
giro e é tão fácil
a cesta mais cara no carnaval estava
vestida adequadamente
eu e os meus amigos até que de repente
fomos mandados parar eu estava a
conduzir o meu carro e comecei a pensar
ok eu tenho os documentos de carros
praia vão implicar comigo porque mas
vamos lutar para voltar ao clube ainda
está tudo bem eu tenho tenho carta verde
tem o cartão do cidadão não há problema
mandaram dispararam polícia e eu pensei
em mostrar mesmo polícia ou só está
mascarada era real eram polícia
fui completamente fiscalizada todos os
documentos mas o presidente disse boa
noite senhor a condutora os seus
documentos por favor leiam os meus
amigos todos calaram o rádio estava
morto e aos meus documentos por favor eu
viajar ir à vila cruzeiro
foi lá que me perguntaram 300 mil vezes
os seus documentos por favor eu no meio
da música na capital um frio de rachar
estava no bar estavam sempre a dizer os
seus documentos por favor eu tinha que
abrir a mochila mostrar tudo aquilo que
tinha
estávamos sempre a perguntar o que está
aqui a fazer porque está aqui pra contar
a verdade
dizia eu mostrava tudo que tinha ou
quase porque pra passar uma fronteira
eu tenho que guardar o meu cartão de
memória conseguiu mais escondido do meu
corpo porque pra passar a fronteira
eu tenho que trazer a verdade daquele
país completamente escondida quando
estava no comboio de regresso da
bielorrússia
caiu a máscara estava a caminho da
lituânia que alguém me pergunta porque é
que foi a vida a você pensar rápido
rápido rápido
em resposta à resposta certa porque eu
não sei quem é que fez essa pergunta e
resposta certa não vai e perguntavam
outra vez porque foi a bielorrússia
eu pensava que era uma ditadura as
pessoas quando se manifestam vão presas
eu não posso responder a verdade e não
responde nada e por isso é estudante e
vai sair boa
são estudantes enfim a verdade são
estudantes
mentira já não estou há alguns anos
perguntaram mas estudante que eu pensei
estudantes que esta difícil que eu digo
que eu digo agora de pessoas histórias
de memórias eu sou estudante de pessoas
enquanto a vida das outras pessoas todos
os dias
na verdade quando eu andava na escola e
as pessoas que contavam a vida dos
outros o que ele chamava era busca agora
são jornalistas
antes a busca aqui gosta tanto de
pesquisa que não fica contente com os
kits de portugal é importante o que eu
faço quando estou contente com as
histórias de portugal a irlanda fora
pelas histórias dos outros contar as
histórias dos outros porque para se
contar as histórias dos outros
eu acredito que tem que viver a história
de deus então há duas semanas
andava de burca e via o mundo através de
uma rede pequenininha e o mundo viana
mandam ver eu era totalmente invisível
porque na minha verdade
eu era mulher estava ali à procura de
fazer o meu trabalho da melhor maneira
para os outros por trás daquela rede
eu não era nada e é atrás daquela rede
eu vi aquilo que cria e vi aquilo que
não cria por trás daquela rede
eu percebi que a minha vantagem de ser
mulher era nem uma desvantagem porque na
síria
ser mulher é ser invisível na síria
ser mulher não ser nada cheguei através
da minha desvantagem ser mulher
por que ninguém perguntou rigorosamente
nada porque eu era invisível e por ser
invisível
eu consegui mostrar a vida dos outros
dados mostraram na verdade deus passou a
ser a minha verdade
costumo dizer só fazem essas maluquices
porque não és mãe mentira eu fui mãe na
guatemala e acontecerá em fila já estava
à espera um dia destes e acontecer mas
eu não queria que tivesse uma tocar e
foi foi não tinha base que é como se
chama na américa latina aos autocarros
da escola que os cubas que nós vemos nos
filmes americanos
três autocarros amarelos que nos estados
unidos levam 50 pessoas na américa
latina levam 500 é temer chegou uma
senhora entrou no autocarro e tinha dois
bebês no colo dos gêmeos ela usou os
gêmeos no primeiro colo que estava livre
o meu fui mãe durante meia hora
fui mãe ao ponto que será que entrou na
passagem seguinte só olhou pra mim eles
para o país só não é igual a todos
eu sou mãe
só não sei quem é o pai
uma vez cheguei ao meu pai
partilhe com muitas coisas ninguém
há uns anos já estava tudo acontece e
disse pai ganhou um prêmio e eu disse
sim eu prometo que é o prémio de
jornalismo estava há poucos anos na
profissão e achei que o máximo eu tinha
candidatado recebi um e mail a dizer
ganhei o primeiro lugar era o máximo
o espetáculo um concurso internacional
israel então o que é que o prêmio uma
viagem uma viagem de graça e meu pai de
uma viagem de graça muito cético paixão
não é uma viagem de graça
a etiópia
meu pai mesmo não espera que ganhaste o
primeiro lugar e vai sair cópia o que
ganhou o último
eu achei que o riva e fui na mesma pra
contrariar
depois dos dias a reportagem a cópia a
cerca de 50 quilômetros da isabella que
é a capital
fui fazer reportagem uma vila e uma
branca chegar a uma reportagem fazer uma
reportagem numa vila africana é uma
festa
aliás muita coisa em áfrica é uma festa
tudo que é diferente é uma festa
os longos cabelos compridos são uma
festa para fazer trenzinho importante
tudo foi uma festa dado momento eu tinha
20 e 30 e 50 crianças à minha volta
uma festa mostraram o sorriso delas a
vida delas
as famílias delas e eu fiz a reportagem
que estava espectacular e imagens lindas
quando vim embora estava a atingir toda
a gente que morou quase o mesmo tempo
que demorou a fazer a reportagem estava
discutindo deus e um menino que estava
sempre ao pé de mim é correr descalça e
com o super sorriso estava entrar no
jipe eu não sei dalin é uma senhora que
grita lá do fundo harris sei quem
sei que levo não posso eu só vou pra
capital não têm oportunidade de voltar
aqui pra trazer ela ficou séria
olha pra mim lá do fundo na mesma série
que sabe que levou era uma ordem
aquela mãe queria que eu trouxesse o
filho dela para portugal
aquela mãe queria que o processo o filho
dela para um futuro melhor porque todas
as mães querem um futuro melhor para
seus filhos a brincar aqui abordado
desta branca era pra ela um futuro
melhor
eram as oportunidades que o filho dela
não queria ter de outra forma
a minha verdade é feita
é verdade dos outros na verdade a
bielo-rússia da síria da etiópia de
portugal a minha verdade é composta por
todos esses bocadinhos daquelas crianças
daquelas pessoas
eu não trouxe o menino física mesmo
trouxe na memória trouxe uma das
histórias
trouxe comigo e eu já deve estar grande
agora a minha verdade é feito tudo isto
é vossa